bienvenue sur cette nouvelle vidéo de
cette chaîne la sociaux tech
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter
un projet très ambitieux puisque je vais
essayer tout en gardant le format qui
est proposée sur cette chaîne à savoir
des vidéos de 5 à 10 minutes vous
proposer un résumé de toute la
distinction de pierre bourdieu donc la
distinction c'est le bouquin le plus
connu de pierre bourdieu
c'est un bouquin qui est à la fois
essentiel pour comprendre les sciences
sociales et la sociologie française mais
tout de suite sans plus tarder le
générique
[Musique]
on dit souvent que les goûts et les
couleurs ne se discutent pas à bien père
bourdieu fait tout le contraire parce
que lui il va en discuter
nos goûts ne sont rien d'autre que des
jugements de valeurs que nous portons
sur des oeuvres d'art des oeuvres de
musique des pratiques des intérieurs des
modes de décoration des modes de vie des
façons de vivre tout ça bourdieu veut
déconstruire cette construction sociale
qui est finalement le goût pour y
arriver il nous propose d'abord une mise
en bouche une entrée en matière dans son
bouquin en nous proposant trois morceaux
de musique alors ici forcément la chaîne
youtube va nous permettre de passer ses
morceaux tu peux l'envoyer la musique
[Musique]
bientôt des collations spéciaux
en
l'autre exagère
tu exagère toujours ne s'est pas fait
sans exagérer
oh
un deuxième morceau
gotham pas toi tu que ce beau
cela l'était bien d'un patois ensuite eh
bien non
les syriens tu connais quand même me
suis tu as déjà entendu ça je n'ai pas
connu ça c'est bizarre tu ne connaissent
pas c'est moche ça bizarre
à savoir on peut s'amuser comme un
passionné de bières
dans le second comment tu sais ça vous
l'avez compris les goûts et les couleurs
c'est difficile d'en discuter comme je
n'ai dit pierre bourdieu choisi d'en
discuter
contrairement à ce que le sens commun
pense le sens commun c'est vous et moi
comme sommes nous en situations
quotidiennes
nous allons penser que ben voilà les
goûts ça dépend des personnes et que
finalement il n'y a pas lieu d'aller
plus loin que ça pierre bourdieu prend
le contre-pied tout ça et va nous
montrer par des enquêtes que les goûts
sont très connoté socialement et que
finalement nous allons avoir des des
strates sociales des couches sociales
qui vont apprécier un certain genre de
musique ici dans ce cas ci mais c'est
valable pour tous les produits où toutes
les productions culturelles ou tout ce
qu'on peut faire dans la vie de tous les
jours et il va nous montrer que par
exemple ici dans les trois morceaux qui
ont été pris les cadres et les
professions intellectuelles supérieures
ou les gens qui ont beaucoup de capitaux
vont apprécier plus tôt bach et le
clavecin tempéré contre le beau danube
bleu est vraiment un morceau qui plaît
aux classes les plus populaires
vous vouliez agriculteurs en premier
rhapsody in blue de gershwin plaît
plutôt aux classes moyennes
comment se fait-il qu'en fonction de
notre position sociale on choisisse
plutôt un style de musique ou un style
de musique nous plaisent plus qu'un
autre et là tout est la question de
pierre bourdieu et tout l'enjeu de la
distinction dans cette vidéo est déjà
finie ce n'était qu'une introduction
bien sûr je vous retrouve dans une
prochaine vidéo qui vous parlera des
capitaux qui sont des concepts
essentiels dans la théorie de benue qui
vont nous permettre de tracer un espace
social au sein duquel évidemment chacun
va se situer cette position définira les
goûts de chacun
je vous remercie pour votre attention
n'oubliez pas les questions en
commentaire et à très bientôt
[Musique]